in the research for this book i spoke to
teenagers at newcomers high school in
new york city which is a high school for
immigrants who have just arrived and
most of the kids i talked to were going
to
celebrate their first thanksgiving in
just a few weeks
and their um
their enthusiasm
for the holiday was um was
very it affected me very profoundly they
identified with the pilgrims now um let
me give you a couple of examples
one um a boy who identified as a tibetan
although that country hasn't existed
since china
took took it over in 1950
he said he was a pilgrim why because his
family like the pilgrims came to america
to practice their religion in china he
said he couldn't practice the
tibetan buddhism of the dalai lama
then a little girl spoke up and she said
oh that's like my family we came here
from egypt because we're cops and cops
are an early
version of christianity an early sect of
christianity
so these kids uh really got it
and um then
a week or two later
after thanksgiving um i went to a
hanukkah party of um a group from my
husband's family
and i met a kid who was attending one of
the most prestigious public high schools
in america hearing that i
wrote a book on thanksgiving he started
he said oh that's the holiday that we
celebrate of
for murdering all the indians
and you know the prestigious high school
okay
yeah so who got it right
i'm dave rubin and joining me on this
very special week is a senior fellow at
the hudson institute author of
thanksgiving the holiday at the heart of
the american experience and the
presenter in the prageru video lincoln
and thanksgiving melanie kirkpatrick
welcome to the reuben report it's
wonderful to be with you especially uh
on thanksgiving week it seemed like you
were the person to talk to on
thanksgiving i have a lot of questions
about thanksgiving you're the are you
the preeminent thanksgiving expert in
america well i i i don't want to sound
modest but uh perhaps so
pretty good all right so i have a lot of
questions about tryptophan but i think
you mostly want to focus on the history
of thanksgiving is that correct
sounds like a good idea though
tryptophan has come up uh you know it's
one of the reasons everybody loves
thanksgiving it helps put you to sleep
puts you to sleep you unbuckle the pants
you're good to go all right so let's
talk because this actually is a very
special thanksgiving thanksgiving 2021
this is the 400th anniversary of
thanksgiving i feel like a lot of people
don't know that so let's do a little 101
what happened 400 years ago back in 1621
the first thing i'll mention is that
there are two
eyewitness accounts by pilgrims of the
first thanksgiving and neither one of
them uses the word thanksgiving
which is kind of interesting that's been
imposed on it over the centuries
the um but it it meets with uh it
dovetails with the pilgrims idea of what
a thanksgiving is it's a day for
expressing gratitude it was always a
religious holiday
but the the event of 1621 uh was
probably more of a harvest festival but
that doesn't mean we can't call it a
thanksgiving because uh if you read
those two first-person accounts
and by pilgrim edwin edward winslow and
william bradford the governor of
plymouth colony
it they present
an event that was very much like the one
we celebrate today at least in spirit
the spirit of gratitude was
at the forefront it was the spirit of
amity with the native americans
it was a time of
sharing it was a time of fellowship
and it was a time of peace
and one of the things i object to is the
modern day progressive
interpretation of that day as the
beginning of
a um period a period you know the the
destruction of the native american
peoples and that's completely wrong
because
if anything the first thanksgiving
points the way to the multicultural
people we have become
because the native americans and the
indians were celebrating together
peacefully and in harmony
yeah so it's hard for a lot of people to
believe that and i don't want to dwell
on it because it's not true you discuss
it in the book you discuss it in the
prageru video but can you just just for
another minute or two just explore that
a little bit that you know people have
this idea that they were they were just
there to kill each other or whatever it
is whatever the modern version of all
this is but really 400 years ago the
native americans and the pilgrims were
sitting down and they were
saying hey we can be thankful together
on this land peacefully together yes yes
they were and um the pilgrims had a lot
to be thankful for for the uh the
assistance of the native americans they
would not have they probably would not
have survived had they not received the
instruction from the native americans on
how to plant where to find good hunting
grounds and good fishing waters
so
and and they knew it if they
there were 52 pilgrims present at that
first thanksgiving and um
most of the only about half of them were
men and yet there were 90
indian
warriors present
so
you can see why they might have been a
little wary and that was probably one
reason that they decided to
have
a
a shooting presentation they showed the
native americans you know how you know
their guns and how they could use them
and it might have been in part a warning
but at the same time um they were very
grateful for the help of the native
americans that made it possible for them
to survive
so you tell the story of thanksgiving
because it didn't it didn't exactly
become a holiday right then and there
that there are two sort of people that
were integral to the story of
thanksgiving one of the people we know
well one we don't know as well although
you just wrote a book i believe about
the second person so tell us about those
two people
oh the first one is president lincoln
and the second is sarah josepha hale and
the lincoln the link between the two of
them is thanksgiving hale was um
the most influential woman of the 19th
century she was editor of goatee's
ladies book
for 50 years and this was one of the
most
widely read and widely circulated
magazines in the 19th century and it's
kind of an amazing story of how a widow
with five five small children rose to
such an exalted position but she did
and uh she was very keen on
using uh well let me back up she was
born in 1788 and she believed
that
while america had been unified
politically through the revolution it
was not unified culturally and she set
out to help do that in her magazines
she
published american authors writing on
american subjects which seems unusual
from the point of view of the 21st
century but back then it was commonplace
for publications to
steal articles from britain or other
publications and republish them without
credit in their own publication but she
had a different vision for her magazine
she wanted to have focus on america and
a focus on american authors
so she published such authors as edgar
allan poe and harry the young harriet
beecher stowe and many many others
but
the idea of thanksgiving
was a part of her vision of um amer
creating an american culture
thanksgiving was very popular in new
england of course and she had grown up
loving the holiday there were
thanksgivings celebrated in the other
states and territories as well
but the uh they were um
the governors of the states didn't
coordinate on the holiday each was and
sometimes some states didn't bother to
celebrate at all
so you had a situation for example in
1837 hale was living in boston which
celebrated on one day she was from new
hampshire which celebrated on another
day and her magazine was headquartered
in
philadelphia and pennsylvania wasn't
celebrating at all that year
so her vision was uh to have americans
celebrate on the same day every year
she thought that giving thanks the idea
of giving coming together to give thanks
as
as a nation
would um help um
she had it had a higher moral principle
she believed and that it would bring the
country together in a positive way
and as the country moved closer to civil
war she hoped that it would prevent
that war
obviously she didn't succeed but in 1863
president lincoln took up her idea which
had been rejected by four previous
presidents
and uh
decided to call a national thanksgiving
so basically it took over 200 years of
sort of a mis-mash of you know who's
doing it when are they doing it why are
they doing it and then finally lincoln
said okay we're all going to do it and
then did everyone kind of fall in place
and immediately say let's do it
yeah the south didn't want to listen to
lincoln during the civil war of course
but the union
rallied very positively to to his call
and after the war um
the southern states um
slowly you know one by one came together
as well on thanksgiving day yeah one of
the things you mentioned in the prageru
video is that the people were actually
eating the same stuff in many cases that
we eat now i mean it was turkey and and
pumpkin pie which is sort of yeah it's
fun that we're still eating the same
stuff a couple hundred years and you
know that goes back much farther than
1863 uh in the 1800s i found exam many
examples of
turkey and pumpkin pie
appearing on thanksgiving menus
so and those uh you know were native um
to the country and so to north america
at least so it's not surprising there
have been many changes in the menu over
the years too
um for example in new england
chicken pot pie was a standard feature
of the thanksgiving buffet
venison also appeared on a lot of
thanksgiving tables and the tradition of
pies was you didn't have just one you
had an array a big selection of pies
at the time
so uh but the from the beginning i think
thanksgiving has been a feast
and that certainly is true today yeah
you know i don't want to focus on the
the cancel culture aspect of this we did
a show on christopher columbus a couple
months ago and i try not to focus on all
of that stuff however this is now a
holiday that is sort of under attack it
represents
the goodness of america and all the good
things that we should be thankful for
and there's an awful lot of people that
that aren't thankful for these days uh
or aren't thankful for everything we
have these days
what can we do to to push back on that
well we can learn the history of the
holiday
for one thing um the teaching of the
holiday has has
been poor over the years
native americans understandably object
to uh what at least when i was growing
up the the focus on uh the generosity of
the pilgrims rather than on the
generosity and assistance of the native
americans so we can get that right in
teaching children about the holiday um i
also think we can um
listen to immigrants when it comes to
their understanding of the holiday the
thanksgiving is a rite of passage for
most immigrants to america it's part of
joining the american family this is a
very positive thing and in the research
for this book i spoke to
teenagers at newcomers high school in
new york city which is a high school for
immigrants who have just arrived and
most of the kids i talked to were going
to
celebrate their first thanksgiving in
just a few weeks
and their um
their enthusiasm
for the holiday was
was
very it affected me very profoundly they
identified with the pilgrims now
let me give you a couple of examples
one um a boy who identified as a tibetan
although that country hasn't existed
since china
took took it over in 1950
he said he was a pilgrim why because his
family like the pilgrims came to america
to practice their religion in china he
said he couldn't practice the
tibetan buddhism of the dalai lama
then a little girl spoke up and she said
oh that's like my family we came here
from egypt because we're cops and cops
are an early
version of christianity an early sect of
christianity
so these kids uh really got it
and um then um a week or two later
after thanksgiving um i went to a
hanukkah party of a group from my
husband's family
and i met a kid who was attending one of
the most prestigious public high schools
in america hearing that i
wrote a book on thanksgiving he started
he said oh that's the holiday that we
celebrate of
uh for murdering all the indians
and you know the prestigious high school
okay
yeah so who got it right so education is
is one thing and let me end on a
positive note here though um you know uh
yes progressives are out to cancel
thanksgiving
but i don't think they have a hope of
success because americans like this
holiday so much and even if they don't
fully grasp the history of it or even if
they pay lip service to
the council culture
they're not going to stop celebrating
thanksgiving and also i think a lot of
the
very positive aspects of thanksgiving
are going to continue families are going
to come together
americans have a tradition of inviting
people who have no place to go for
thanksgiving and most of all
i love the idea of thanksgiving
generosity which the idea that
thanksgiving is a holiday when we think
carefully about those who are less
fortunate among us and you think of all
the non-profits all the non-religious
all the religious organizations and also
all the individuals who make sure that
people who are in jail people who are in
hospital and people who have
no family all have an opportunity to
have a good thanksgiving dinner
and this is
um this is a real hallmark of the
holiday and of american generosity yeah
and i have to say that you know over the
last couple years as as some of our
freedoms have felt like they're
disappearing or at least being
challenged in very bizarre ways i've
definitely become more appreciative i've
always loved thanksgiving because of the
food and the smells and the people and
the family and all that you mentioned at
the beginning that this was really
thought of as a religious holiday at
first which is sort of uh not the way i
think most people think of it because
they think of it sort of as our main
secular holiday in america can you talk
about that a little bit yeah i think a
better way to think of it dave is that
it is um
um
the only holiday
probably anywhere in the world
that is open to all religions and to
none
so
it's um you know doesn't matter what
your religion is it doesn't matter uh
where you came from this is
every amer it is every american's
holiday
so uh
yeah it used to be even when i was
growing up that uh people went to church
uh you know the night before
thanksgiving or thanksgiving morning
that doesn't happen very much anymore
but if there is a day
that a family says grace before a meal
it is thanksgiving day
yeah so you mentioned before that uh
abraham lincoln obviously first we have
the civil war so now he's got to get the
the south to kind of come on board all
of this was was everybody immediately
celebrating thanksgiving after or did it
really take some time
it it took a while i i don't recall off
the top of my head the dates when uh
southern states individually began to
celebrate but um certainly by the end of
the 19th beginning of the 20th century
it was a unit there was unity in the
states and let me tell you a funny story
about what happened um in the 1930s
during the depression
fdr had the dumb idea that if he moved
the date of thanksgiving to allow more
time between thanksgiving day and
christmas and eric it would help the
economy
his theory was that americans would have
more days to go christmas shopping and
that would be a boost to the holiday
well i think americans would have liked
to spend more money on christmas
presents but they didn't have the money
right so
the idea flopped
but um and for three three days though
americans
had to
either celebrate on the new day which
was a week earlier than the traditional
date or um celebrate on the traditional
date and the country was split about 50
50
and
the holiday began known as became known
as the democratic thanksgiving and the
republican thanksgiving which was very
funny but uh there were a few states
that had the best idea of all they
celebrated on both days and i know texas
and colorado were among them i've
forgotten what the third is
um but
then in 1941 it was clear that
roosevelt's idea for a new date for
thanksgiving was a flop and congress
finally acted and passed a resolution
naming the fourth thursday of thanks of
november as the official thanksgiving
date and finally thanksgiving
was written into law and we've
celebrated on that date ever since as a
thanksgiving historian does it madden
you that friday after thanksgiving has
now become black friday which is now
leaking into thanksgiving i mean the new
thing is now that the store is open
actually on thanksgiving day the one day
we're supposed to set aside to be
thankful and we've allowed it to become
this sort of commercial madness
yeah i don't like the leakage into
thanksgiving thursday i i
say but i like i i don't mind black
friday
i think it's actually a sign of the
health of our economy the prosperity of
the american people and we should give
thank we should pay thanks
give thanks for that how did football
oh go ahead well football yeah
what about football yeah how did
football become a part of this whole
thing i thought football was supposed to
be on sundays
well i uh
i am not a fan of football and this was
the hardest chapter for me right
but i had a lot you know i did a lot of
research and i i got it um
as you may recall the the first american
football game was
played by princeton and rutgers in
1869
and then in the 70s
princeton which is my alma mater i will
say
uh and yale played a thanksgiving day on
play a thanksgiving day football game it
was their championship game
that moved to new york city in the late
7 1870s or or around 1880 and new
yorkers took it up even if they couldn't
go to the game they came out in force
walking the streets they would go up and
down fifth avenue wearing orange and
black for pris for princeton or blue for
yale
and they really adopted this football
championship game in a big way
and of course new yorkers have always
been trend setters and the rest of the
country began to take up the idea of
thanksgiving day football a lot of um
towns would have heist town high schools
would have their championship game on
thanksgiving morning and then go home
for for dinner
and then
i guess some people um had the idea in
the early 20th century that uh this
would be good for pro football too and
the detroit tigers were the first team
to play a thanksgiving day game which
they of course still play
and then the dallas cowboys took it up
at some point
and
now there's a third team which i think
changes every year that that plays
but
thanksgiving football was controversial
in the 19th century
ministers and rabbis and others
complained that it took it diverted
attention from the true meaning of the
day
but uh you know uh i i think we can have
turkey and thanks and football and
gratitude all in the same day we can
multitask americans look at that
although i'm sure there were some people
of course that probably felt that people
shouldn't be you know forced to work
that day or that sort of thing too but
you think we can fit all things what are
some of the crazier traditions you've
heard i assume that there's all sorts of
different
thanksgiving traditions all over the
country
gosh yeah there are but you know
the meal is the number one
um
is the number one tradition and
um
sarah josefa hale whom i mentioned is
the the godmother of the modern day
thanksgiving
um uh used uh she was the first one to
bring recipes to put recipes in a
magazine or newspaper to create a recipe
section and she published lots of
recipes culled from around the country
for thanksgiving day feasts and
um
uh you know
you hear i heard of some crazy pies like
sweet potato pie i had never heard of
that but apparently it's popular in the
south
and um there's a pie called marlboro pie
which is a kind of apple lemon pie which
was very popular in the 19th century
um but crazy customs a lot of people go
over this isn't crazy but a lot of
people go round the table and ask
every individual
to say something that he is grateful for
other families read
find something to read about
thanksgiving for
the the family table and um i actually
at the back of my thanksgiving book
include readings for thanksgiving day
and they're
short very short readings from over 400
years of american history about
thanksgiving and then there's a custom
that my family has adopted
i won't call it a crazy custom but it's
a different custom it's called five
kernels of corn and it dates back to the
late 19th centuries of
people would put five kernels of dried
corn on their table and the corn
represented um
the generosity of the native people who
taught
the pilgrims how to grow corn and it
also represented the starving time of
the plymouth of the pilgrims in plymouth
colony
when they um
by legend says we're given only five
kernels of corn to eat every day
so um i like that i like that idea five
kernels of corn
how does our thanksgiving some of the
traditions the foods all that compare
you know like we just uh had canadian
thanksgiving was a couple weeks ago i
assume other countries have some version
maybe not called thanksgiving but you
know sort of a more secular day of
thanks type of thing
well most of the uh thanksgivings
around the world are religious in nature
um or at least originated as such china
has a kind of thanksgiving it's more of
a harvest festival um so does uh
the two so did the two koreas
brazil uh has a thanksgiving that is
modeled on the american thanksgiving the
ambassador from brazil to america in the
late 1940s loved thanksgiving and so he
went home and took it with him to brazil
and they now have such a holiday
and canada's holiday is interesting it
um it's on our columbus day weekend
and uh it's uh
it
the idea of celebrating thanksgiving was
carried from by
carried to canada by british loyalists
who american loyalists excuse me who
fled during the revolution to usually
nova scotia and um because there was a
close tie between boston and halifax at
the time and they took the holiday with
them and it's spread around
the country of canada it doesn't have
the same meaning for canadians though
that it has for americans because it's
not it doesn't have an association with
anything in the canadian history
so it's while canadians enjoy the day
and
have a meal a harvest meal that's
similar to ours um
they don't feel the connection to it
that we feel interesting so it really
was an export from us to them yeah in
that sense yeah yeah
yeah interesting
what else what else do people need to
know on this thanksgiving before i let
them dive into their turkey and stuffing
and all that good stuff there sweet
potato pie
well
in response to your comment about uh
your question about black friday i also
wanted to mention giving tuesday which
you may have heard of it's a it's a new
a relatively new
um
campaign which is start was originally
organized by the um
92nd street y in new york city which
is
a has jewish roots and the idea was
to set up online opportunities for
people to donate to their favorite uh
nonprofits and charities it's been very
successful it's um
raised millions it raises millions and
millions of dollars every year and i
love the idea that
giving tuesday is
uh connected originally to our
thanksgiving day do you know the actual
website we can send people to we'll find
it if not
well i don't you i believe the way it
works is that um
uh you go well i'm not sure
yeah see if you can find a link that
would be great i'm guessing there's a
giving tuesday website but if not
obviously on that tuesday before
thanksgiving you can you can donate to
wherever you'd like well we're gonna
link to the prageru video down below
we're gonna link to the book which i've
got right here
and i've enjoyed this talk and
i can very simply say happy thanksgiving
to you and back to you dave i wish you
and your family a very happy
thanksgiving
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about academia
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our academia playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist they're all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell